PURGE, THAT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
WITH LIBERALS HAVING MONOPOLIZED
THE FIELDS OF JOURNALISM,
ACADEMIA, AND THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY FOR DECADES, YOU WOULD
THINK THEY WOULD BE HAPPIER
PEOPLE BUT THEY ARE NOT.
IN THE AGE OF TRAUMA, MANY
DEMOCRATS, HARDCORE POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS AND THE ELITES IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY JUST
SEEMED MISERABLE AND PERPETUALLY
ANGRY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A GUY WHO YOU
UNDERSTAND HE HURTS YOU AND MY
TESTOSTERONE SOMETIMES MAKES ME
FEEL LIKE PUNCHING HIM.
>> [BLEEP]
>> WE NEED SOMEBODY WHO CAN
TAKE THIS GUY ON, AND PUNCH HIM
IN THE FACE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A FLAMING
RACIST FLAMING RACIST.
>> Laura: THEY ALL MOUTH
PLATITUDES OF LOVING DIVERSITY
BUT THEY WANT NONE OF IT.
THEY WANT CONSERVATIVES BANISHED
FROM THE PUBLIC SQUARE AND
TREATED LIKE POLITICAL LEPERS.
IF YOU'RE A TRUMP SUPPORTER, YOU
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE ALLOWED TO DO
A GUEST SPOT ON THE TV SHOW.
REMEMBER WHEN THAT STORY BROKE
ONE FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY SEAN SPICER WOULD BE A
CONTESTANT IN THE NEW SEASON OF
"DANCING WITH THE STARS," HOST
TOM BERGERON PROTESTED.
>> MY PREFERENCE, IT'S NOT MY
CALL.
OTHER PEOPLE BOOK THE SHOW --
WOULD HAVE BEEN TO AVOID ANY
POLITICAL LIGHTNING RODS.
I THINK DANCING AT ITS BEST IS
AN OASIS AWAY FROM ALL OF THE
DIVISIVENESS AND ALL OF THE
STUFF THAT WE ARE ALL WRESTLING
WITH RIGHT NOW.
>> Laura: WRESTLING, DANCING.
RIGHT ON CUE, REPORTERS AT CNN
VOMITED OUT THIS HEADLINE, CHECK
IT OUT.
IT CITES NINE UNNAMED SOURCES
AFFILIATED WITH ABC'S NEWS
DIVISION AND ONE SOURCE SAID
IT'S DISGUSTING TO THINK HE'S
GETTING ON THE SHOW AND GETTING
PAID BY OUR COMPANY.
IT'S REALLY THE SHAREHOLDERS
COMPANY, IDIOT.
ABOUT HALF OF THEM WILL PROBABLY
VOTE FOR TRUMP.
WHAT IS TRULY DISGUSTING IS THE
RABID PARTISANSHIP AT A FORMERLY
VERY RESPECTED NEWS AGENCY LIKE
"ABC NEWS" ."
NOBODY HAD ANY QUALMS ABOUT
HIRING GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS
FROM BILL CLINTON'S WHITE HOUSE,
AND I LIKE HIM, HE'S ALWAYS BEEN
KIND TO ME WHEN I'VE BEEN ON
ABC.
HE'S NOT A COMMENTATOR, HE'S ONE
OF THE MARQUEE NEWS POSTS AND
THE LEFT IS FINE WITH THAT.
SEAN SPICER, IS HE GOING TO BE
ATTEMPTING THE TANGO?
IT'S SOMEHOW AN AFFRONT TO THE
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY AT ABC.
PLEASE.
YESTERDAY, THIS IS UNREAL, THE
MISS NEVADA PAGEANT WINNER KATIE
WILLIAMS WAS STRIPPED OF HER
CROWN AFTER SHE DARED TO EXPRESS
PRO-TRUMP VIEWS ON HER PERSONAL
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNT.
>> MANY EMAILS OF THE
COORDINATORS EMAILING ME SAYING
THAT I'M "TOO POLITICAL" TO BE
IN THE PAGEANT.
WHEN I WOULD REPLY BACK AND ASK
WHAT I COULD DO OR ANYTHING
ELSE, THEIR BASIC ANSWER WAS TO
DELETE EVERYTHING ON MY PAGE.
I ASKED WHAT WAS THE ACTUAL
CONTENT THEY DIDN'T LIKE AND
THEY WOULD NEVER GIVE ME AN
ANSWER.
>> Laura: WOULD SHE HAVE
GOTTEN BOOTED IF SHE WAS A
CLIMATE CHANGE ALARMIST OR AT
PLANNED PARENTHOOD SUPPORTER?
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER.
NOW MISS WILLIAMS WILL BE
JOINING US AND MOMENTS TO TELL
US MORE.
EVEN BILLIONAIRE SPORTS MOGULS
AREN'T SAFE FROM THE LEFTIST
PURGE PATROL.
MIAMI DOLPHINS OWNER STEVE ROSS
IS BEING EJECTED FROM THE
LEAGUE'S SOCIAL JUSTICE
COMMITTEE -- BY THE WAY, IT'S
COMMITTEE HE FOUNDED.
THE REASON?
HE DARED TO HOST A TRUMP
FUND-RAISER.
[SHOUTING]
THIS BLACKLISTING AND
INTIMIDATION AND PUBLIC SHUNNING
AS PART OF A PATTERN THAT HAS
INTENSIFIED SINCE THE ELECTION
OF TRUMP.
>> IF YOU SEE ANYBODY FROM THAT
CABINET, THAT RESTAURANT, AT A
GASOLINE STATION, YOU TELL THEM
THEY AREN'T WELCOME, ANYMORE,
ANYWHERE.
>> GET UP AND GET UP IN THE FACE
OF SOME CONGRESSPEOPLE.
>> WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE GO
HIGH -- NO.
WHEN THEY GO LOW, WE KICK THEM.
>> Laura: WE KNOW WHAT THAT
HATEFUL TALK ENCOURAGED, MORE
PEACE AND UNDERSTANDING?
WE SAW PROMINENT CONSERVATIVES
HARASSED IN PUBLIC.
[SHOUTING]
>> Laura: THESE PEOPLE DON'T
EVEN WANT CONSERVATIVES TO BE
ABLE TO RELAX IN THE SANCTITY OF
THEIR OWN HOME.
>> THAT'S PROBABLY WHAT IT IS.
JUST STAB THE [BLEEP] IN THE
HEART, PLEASE.
>> Laura: UNIVERSITIES DON'T
EXPECT CONSERVATIVES TO GET
TREATED ANY BETTER.
[CHANTING]
>> Laura: IF YOU ARE A RETIREE
OR A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO
DONATES TO TRUMP CAMPAIGN, YOU
ARE ALSO NOT IMMUNE.
YOU TOO CAN BE TARGETED AND EVEN
DOXXED BY YOUR OWN CONGRESSMAN,
NO LESS.
>> I HOPE THESE DONORS IN
SAN ANTONIO AND DONORS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY, UNLESS
YOU SUPPORT THE WHITE
NATIONALISM AND THE RACISM THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS PAYING FOR AND
FUELING, I HOPE YOU AS A PERSON
OF GOOD CONSCIENCE WILL THINK
TWICE ABOUT CONTRIBUTING TO HIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
BLAME TRUMP'S RHETORIC FOR THE
RECENT EL PASO MASS SHOOTING USE
AS HE DOES THE MOST VICIOUS,
TOXIC LANGUAGE TO SMEAR THEIR
POLITICAL ADVERSARIES.
FORGET THE REAL DEBATE, JUST
SMEAR THEM.
IT'S ALL WITH THE GOAL OF MAKING
THEM SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
OUTCASTS.
♪ ♪
>> GOD BE WITH YOU.
>> Laura: THEY WOULD PROBABLY
SEND US ALL TO LEPER COLONIES IF
THEY COULD.
DO THEY REALLY THINK MOST
AMERICANS SUPPORT THESE
MALICIOUS EFFORTS, THEIR
LANGUAGE?
I DON'T.
I THINK OUR CITIZENS DISAGREE
VIGOROUSLY BUT THEY ARE
FAIR-MINDED PEOPLE AND THEY
DON'T LIKE TO SEE THEIR
NEIGHBORS OR FRIENDS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE LIVING IN
FEAR OF EXPRESSING THEIR VIEWS.
SO MANY CONSERVATIVES TODAY COME
UP AND TELL ME I'M REALLY QUIET
ABOUT WHAT I BELIEVE, AFRAID OF
SAYING THE WRONG THING AT WORK,
THEY ARE ALL AFRAID COME ALL THE
TIME.
THE CULTURAL AND POLITICAL
PROGRESSIVES, I THINK THEY OUGHT
TO BE VERY CAREFUL.
WHILE DEMONIZING CONSERVATIVES
AND DRIVING THEM UNDERGROUND MAY